[Music]
in Cheers news - submitted by caesar and
luke gay all that's two first names
nearly 500 residents chipped in to save
their favorite local bar that's those
years
cheaters everybody knows they can't save
it that way let it burn to the ground
yeah so then don't be clever this
village and in Britain I would never
love drinking do we have is that a bar
in the pub the place where I live is
called Tonga village was England and
Britain the same thing yeah Great
Britain has a friendship it has Ireland
and has a power encompassing I think
it's a bunch of kingdoms that owns a
bunch of cars that United Kingdom
England United Kingdom England they they
saved their pub called the pack horse in
which has been open so they're
speculating that there oh so officially
they're saying it opened in 1600 oh [ __ ]
that's worth saving for sure what's up
they have buildings from back then we
don't have that I wish I had a historic
pub to go to it's [ __ ] awesome
[ __ ] issues there were beheadings
there always in any time you tell me
some shits old I'm like it's haunted
yeah has to be yeah they're saying that
yeah but the building was erected in
1674 but historians argue that this
place has been around since 1498 Baker
flog argue all day that's an all last
time yeah
no 14 is 16 that's that's still all
clumped together anything over a hundred
that's just old
never happy with conversation or say
anything before 1800 it was like that's
just [ __ ] all that no matter what
like their entertainment was watching
people die in public yeah that was all
that was but it could also mean the
difference between pre-renaissance in
the Dark Ages or a Polish Renaissance
era yeah what's the difference Noel what
is the deficit a huge difference guys
which one had dragons I didn't watch the
next episode of the History Channel's
huh you know how they have like ad and
like BC and [ __ ] we should just have old
ass [ __ ] oh yeah anything anything under
eighteen hundred Oh anything between the
dinosaurs and eighteen hundred nobody
remembers jack [ __ ] so y'all debating
over [ __ ] [ __ ] rumors for me I've
always had this theory now that we're
getting more into the internet age that
in the future is not gonna be BC and AD
it's gonna be before internet posting oh
yeah I feel like the internet changed
the [ __ ] game and it's still evolving
man and like we're gonna look at the
world
oh that's before the internet happened
yeah then now we got [ __ ] yeah cuz we
started getting to this conversation of
like a hundred years from now or 200
years from now like I wonder if people
are still gonna see time the same how we
see time with like anything pass 1800
it's like who cares that was a long time
ago
I wonder if we're gonna be significant
and nothing right he's imagine it's like
people clumping like the 1950s to 2050
that's all the same [ __ ] I don't know
what the [ __ ] they were still driving on
the ground yeah anything pre-internet
is like caveman times we're like oh they
they used hieroglyphics back then right
on the paper what the [ __ ] is that at a
rate cursive these curly letters that's
experienced [ __ ] yeah yeah so anyway
this is the pack horse and osq it's like
a little cottage that's old people -
everything's [ __ ] over there
that looks like a massive funnel cake
[Laughter]
ooh work will building like they're
about to cook some [ __ ] you know what's
crazy if you just mess with the filters
and make it look sepia then now it looks
like it's from like nothing [ __ ]
changed in that photo also when people
when buildings have little windows and
little bricks like that at almost all
he's looking at yeah we're like it's
like an old orphanage
it's got abused in there that's what it
looks like a big change I was picturing
like stained glass like a pub look good
oh yeah like yield public a Harry Potter
tax when the time actually matters when
it's built it's this type of
architecture that's okay Bart you win
gothic why does [ __ ] always gotta
look scary yes but like why can't it be
like Disneyland repenting people back
then you had to be scared and they lived
in fear well I mean Amsterdam is old as
[ __ ] but that looks like it's cute those
fools are silly they're silly the
buildings look it looks like tuned down
yeah yeah but then there's also like
Anne Frank's attic is there and stuff so
sure cuz oh like no matter where you are
in the world like whether it's China or
Japan or whatever the old buildings look
scary yes but I know check out this
photo I don't know what you're this is
also the Peck horses I don't you
my Instagram filter yes what does it use
your like lightning happening in the
back Ray yeah there's needs to be a body
dangling from one of those streams looks
like a murder-mystery house like one of
the maids or something it's got to be in
black and white like really sharp black
really sharp white yeah yeah they were
saying that they even found priests hold
like you stick your dick - yeah what a
priest hole yeah you can't drop the bomb
and walk away I mean guys we're gonna do
yeah so these are so back in the 16th
century they wore the 14th century
architecture guys the 13th century don't
just take like one number if it's like
the 14 hundreds or something oh no
anyway so back in the 16th century they
would hide Catholics Catholic priests oh
my gosh they would hide Catholic priests
because Catholic clergymen were targeted
because of several assassination plots
against Queen Elizabeth the first Oh
so apparently they would have these
holes where they would hide priests and
they put alcohol in the hole or no well
I was thinking of a different hole but
that's good okay it was like more of a
holy glory hole yeah that's what I was
thinking but with alcohol that gets
poured into your mouth here that
comments well because you can't drink
yeah and cuz you're hiding from they
can't [ __ ] but they can't drink oh
that's worse right but the hand drank
beer our ale or oh wow may the Kings me
that's simple simple when you made fun
of me that she speaks the Old English
[Laughter]
in the daytime it feels like you know
it's like something out of a Disney
movie like Snow White's gonna pop out or
whatever I was picturing stained glass
yeah what at my time like this yeah like
[ __ ] Count Dracula lives there and
[ __ ] and then they probably had
candlesticks is my thing you see this
like glowing in the shadows a European
[ __ ] is scary as [ __ ] yeah mm-hmm Asian
sure it's not that scary old Asian
should add anything old like dynasty
like cool-looking Tower things that go
like this that's true cool look elegant
any day time right there just like
sipping do but even like just the
Japanese like what's the the wall may
not have like the paper paper that
doesn't look scary yeah I tell you open
you see a [ __ ] ninja there way to
kill you oh you're right you know what
I'm scared up it's it's a black tea
scary when we go to the temples and all
that like the statues or the things
that's what I'm scared of not the
buildings the buildings don't look like
anything you know things aren't creepy
yeah
the buildings make me feel even ninjas
aren't creepy scary if they're more just
like oh yeah it's like an action movie I
bet you say you feel safe I didn't do
anything wrong I would feel safe I'd be
like dang they're gonna go kill someone
not me
what's they're really good at like one
punch like you're dead like I feel like
I'd go out nice and peacefully that way
we probably just never saw too many I
ghost movie horror films from Asia or
something like I feel like a lot of this
stuff that we're afraid of of the
Western culture is because we've seen a
lot of movies you've seen a lot of
elements that were made scary that was
scariest horror movies are from Japan
like the ring the original ring with
their modern day stuff though they're
not set in the old days I feel like if
they made it scary it's not like ancient
have embedded in her Minds to be sir
vampires we're likely cute push it in
there until you kill someone how did it
go there's like good there'll be like
the scene where a guys like hiding like
in another room like that and the
vampire just goes right through the wall
and just tears off fools heart out
through the drywall it's just scary
that's sure it's not creepy yes it's
like shocking yeah yeah that's true
though maybe you're right and how your
parents are scary but they're not creepy
scary they're just all that might beat
my ass scary yeah cuz all the movies
that we do watch samurai movies kung fu
movies or whatever when I when I see
those buildings I just want to [ __ ]
meditate like a [ __ ] yeah yeah
or kickback stereotyping my own kind
like I go there and I'm just like oh yes
so honored to be here you know like yeah
even like the deaths are like honor
death yeah like the ghosts are like
don't worry I was honorable the way but
yeah back to this pub though the entire
village they were able to raise 1
million pounds David yeah you know
what's nice is that they probably don't
even have good drinks there cuz when we
went to England like they did not have
good yeah yeah it's in France two tabs
you gotta go to Germany yeah we did we
went to Germany to wear it we went to
Berlin to GG they just have European
beer so they'd like the recipes were
from back in the day from like I go to
Munich you gotta go to Munich okay
Oktoberfest and the beer is ball well do
you drink a lot of beer cuz if you trade
our craft beers here in America because
they're like [ __ ] son I've been drinking
beer before there that was even a theme
ah because Americans we took the
old-time recipes and we made them better
but they just keep their same old
traditional recipes or like this was the
first beer forever
and you're like you dude they have a
lemon
innovations to beer down which is bomb
it says lemonade and beer I've never had
that
it's called Mike's Hard Lemonade drink
that's like some [ __ ] [ __ ] like this
one was a good balance okay like a cider
no didn't realize we had some alcoholics
here yo I work connected back there so
no know where that [ __ ] negative
together you need to go to a beer hall
where the men are wearing daisy dukes
with the Peter Pan hat playing a [ __ ]
accordion as this small with [ __ ]
suspenders that sounds but his real
beard Johan or that's the tourist trap
they tell you that they're locals
[Music]
[Music]